My name is Maya Greyy,
and I have a YouTube channel
where I express my creativity
and show the love for my dolls.
I'm going to be walking you guys through
on how I restored this
Bratz Campfire Felicia doll.
Felicia is from the Campfire line
that Bratz released in 2005.
Even though she was very underrated
when she first came
out, she quickly became
one of the most sought-after
dolls to this day.
Felicia pretty much came
with her full outfit.
She came with a haircut,
a missing left brow, and lip chips.
And she also came with marks on her body,
which looked like pens or like crayons.
I'm going to be undressing the doll
just to make it easier for me
and just to wash the clothes as well,
since they came very dirty.
I'm going to be taking her head off,
which is going to help
me with cutting her hair,
removing what's inside as well.
Her hair came very chopped.
It was cut short.
I'm just going to be using some scissors
to cut her hair.
And you want to make sure
that you're cutting down to the roots,
pretty much just to get rid of it
and have a clean slate
for the new rerooted hair.
I'm going to be putting her hair
into boiling-hot water,
and this will soften up her vinyl,
like the plastic, the head,
to make it easier for you
to pluck the hair out.
And it also does soften
the glue inside the head.
I'm going to be using pointy tweezers
to pretty much pick out the remaining hair
that's inside the head,
just to make it cleaner
and easier for the reroot,
and there's no remaining hair
that's going to be poking
out with all of her new hair.
Rerooting is pretty much replacing
all of her hair that's already rooted.
I'm going to be using saran hair,
which is pretty much the same
as her factory hair that she came with.
And I also picked out
the most similar colors that I could find,
just to match it all exactly.
So, using a rerooting tool,
I'm going to be poking
each hair into the head
pretty much exactly how
they did it in the factory.
I used the base of an
X-Acto knife, a needle,
and I have a pick to help
me poke holes into the doll
just to make it easier for the needle.
And it will also save you some needles,
because it will break if
the hole isn't big enough
or the plastic has hardened.
So, starting off with the reroot,
I just sectioned out some hair
to make it easier for me.
Each strand of hair I pretty much
wrap around my finger.
I use that to guide the needle
and guide the hair into the needle.
I use my pick to create a bigger hole
into the doll's head,
and then after that I
use my rerooting tool
to insert the hair into the doll's head.
Some of the existing
holes might be already
too big or already cracked.
So if you're using a pick
to widen up the holes,
just be careful just in case
you might crack a big hole into her head
or crack the plastic even more.
So, the doll came with some pen marks
all over her body.
I'm going to be using some alcohol,
since it kind of stained the plastic.
She came with chipped
brows and chipped lips,
so I'm just going to be repainting them
using some acrylic paint
and some nail polish that I have.
I just use a normal paintbrush
typically used for doll repaints.
And these are usually smaller
than normal paintbrushes,
since it's for detailing.
During repainting, it's important
to have a steady hand.
If there's any mistakes
that I've done with the repainting,
I'm going to be using some rubbing alcohol
just to remove some of the imperfections
or just to clean up the
repainting just a little bit,
just to make her eyebrow more sharp.
So, with repainting her lips,
I used nail polish that
was pretty much clear,
and I used some eye shadow
that was pretty similar
to her lip color that I found.
So it was pretty lucky.
So I just mixed the clear nail polish
and the eye shadow together
just to have a paint consistency,
and I just used that to repaint her lips.
I pretty much just used a normal
washing detergent for her clothes
and used it with some lukewarm water.
So I pretty much just kind of
scrunch it up in the water,
just making sure all
the dirt is out of it.
You can see by the water
how dirty the clothes came in.
So it was definitely a
good decision to wash them.
I'm going to be redressing her
back into the clothes that she came with.
They are the original clothes
from the Campfire line,
just some pieces missing.
I am very happy with this restoration,
and I'm happy to have Felicia
in my doll collection,
since she is very sought after
and very loved by a lot of collectors.